609 on your thursday morning we continue
our look at the city's most dangerous
intersections maybe you've noticed a
pattern emerging as metro and the unlv
road equity alliance's aaron breen point
out there is more to it than just
listing the intersections with the most
crashes now in part four
once again human behavior is front and
center
we're at flamingo and pecos but it can
be as dangerous as any intersection
anywhere in the valley you've got three
through lanes in all four directions
you've got bus stops you have
pedestrians
plus there's the curvature of pecos
mcleod to the north between here in d.i
but it was actually to the south of here
on pecos between flamingo and trop that
aaron breen ran into an issue i thought
i was going to lose my life because
three
idiots were racing each other down pecos
they had to be going 70 miles an hour
in and out of traffic cutting cars off
you know there's a police substation
right there at harmon in pecos you know
so
it
you just never know where it's going to
be
and don't you
and every driver you know have a similar
story so yeah the number of crashes at
various intersections might influence
your driving choices of where to go or
not go but working to reduce crashes
everywhere
is something we all can do especially
the people who need to hear it most and
that's the people who don't hear it at
all
now we've got one more stop tomorrow
focused on a bigger picture but i think
the bigger picture for all of us is that
we can change these dangerous
intersections yeah
dangerous because of us